comme la plupart des centres de
protection maternelle infantile la pmi
du morne-rouge ne serait plus en mesure
d'assurer la sécurité des enfants
qu'elles accueillent ici aux problèmes
d'insalubrité et d'entretien des locaux
s'ajouterait un manque évident de
personnel et en particulier de médecins
mais difficile de les attirer dans ces
conditions je tombais sur les enfants
francine exercice' son métier
d'infirmière depuis plus de 12 ans elle
a vu la situation se dégrader très
nettement ces dernières années
bientôt pas d'avoir un palace cinq
étoiles simplement à l'entretien la
maintenance parce que même si le local
il est ancien quand il est bien
entretenu et ça peut suffire
il suffit d'avoir une ligne téléphonique
il suffit d'avoir un minimum vital et
d'étoilés glissante et un nettoyage
régulier
les agents évoque des infestations de
rades scolopendre ou de ravet des
cabinets de consultation sans le moindre
point d'eau et parle de risque de
contamination
la situation ne pouvait plus durer alors
réparations exigées manque de médecins
manquent de sages-femmes manque de
chauffeurs le manque de matériel aussi
ou du matériel défectueux
le manque de salubrité des locaux
aujourd'hui le bébé que la ctm a à
charge un handicap
et bien il faut prendre le bébé avec son
handicap et s'en occuper de façon à ce
que son handicap ne l' entrave pas dans
son développement à la ctm on se dit
surpris par ce mouvement qui intervient
alors que des discussions sont déjà
engagés avec les représentants du
personnel
nous avons repris wade vous le 9 en
tenant compte de la période des vacances
le 9 novembre pour un face de chaque
revendication apporter des réponses
précises ce qui est posé c'est un
problème qui existe depuis très
longtemps c'est la qualité des bâtiments
où se trouve ce personnel
la remise aux normes des locaux auraient
même été prise en compte dans les
dernières orientations budgétaires de la
collectivité des rénovations qui vont
faire pas à pas les mamans les enfants
et le personnel des pmi devront donc
encore prendre leur mal en patience